the idea of sanctuary cities of saying
hey we're a city where if you're illegal
meaning you're a criminal by default
you've come into this country illegally
you are not supposed to be here you are
a criminal uh you can stay here you can
stay here you can work here you can get
benefits here we'll give you covet shots
everything else
democrats seem to be for this and even
now
they're for it here's new york city
mayor eric adams just over a year ago
you tweeted quote new york city will
remain a sanctuary city under an ad
adams administration what is your
message to migrants arriving in the u.s
should they still come to new york city
well i think that they should come to
any place in the country that they
desire of their pursuit of the american
dream
i don't know how that man got the job
well i guess i do know because people
were so fed up with that ridiculous bill
de blasio who was openly a socialist and
a communist and then there were all
these people there that thought oh eric
adams will be a little bit better a
little bit better
eric adams that in some ways that almost
is an impeachable statement when you are
an elected official
it is your job to defend the laws
whether you're the president of the
united states you have to defend the
federal laws you have to abide by the
constitution if you're the mayor there
are laws in the city of new york that
you have to abide by
you can't just say okay yeah you can
come and the fact that he's so tone deaf
so you know what i say more than in that
case
governor desantis if you're watching
this or governor abbott in texas if
you're watching this
keep sending them to new york the mayor
just said that he wants them so let's
just exacerbate the situation i don't
mean that sort of to be a dick i mean
that because we have to get this to its
end it has to get to its volition
where democrat cities will be exactly
what they say
that they want and republican cities and
states will be lawful
there will be they will be clean and
pleasant and have flourishing economies
and they will be safe and everything
else oh and get this one this is just an
incredible video i cannot believe that
they didn't blow up the msnbc truck as
this was broadcasting here is an msnbc
reporter uh talking about how actually
the people showing up to martha's
vineyard they like desantis
now i can tell you they are not angry at
ron desantis they are actually thanking
him for having brought them to martha's
vineyard where they were they were very
well received but other people will
they're saying they're being used as
political pawns they don't resent it for
now and they know they're the lucky ones
okay so these 50 people they show up at
martha's vineyard martha's vineyard's a
lovely place and apparently it has all
these nice tolerant decent people some
of them even baked them cakes and things
and then they booted them within 24
hours and they got those 150 soldiers
there and everything else and they
probably took down their you know no
humanist illegal sign from there from
their lawn
but the point is that these people were
not abused in any way the if you want to
talk about the abuse of these people the
abuse of these people is an
administration that sends signals that
you can come to our border and get in
our country and then our mayors that say
yes come here those mayors like eric
adams not only is eric adams abusing
the the illegal immigrants right he's
abusing them because the city cannot
sustain them right we know this and
muriel bowser and dc the city is running
out of beds and homeless shelters
because of all the illegals but then
you're abusing your own citizens your
own citizens who have a right to your
city services who have a right to clean
streets and to have a right to be able
to walk down the street and not be
attacked or raped or anything else